good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday happy
first day back of maternity leave being
over welcome back to the show for a
permanent amount of time it is jackie oh
hi i'm so excited to be here for a
permanent amount of time
my maternity leave is officially over i
don't know you guys are like wait you've
been here what's the difference now like
no more guest co-hosts every other day
i am back
i'm here to stay hopefully you know
things continue to go according to plan
but you know at three months like the
baby really is changed on a schedule on
a schedule he's like so busy at this
time of day doing haralds and tings and
mama's got to work mama's gotta put milk
on the table mama's gotta put milk in
her titties milk and her titties milk on
the table and so
now yeah i'm back this was really my
plan and it went according to plan 100
after one month i was back one day a
week after two months i was back two to
three days a week after three months i'm
back permanently and i just want to say
like when i made the plan i didn't
know what to expect right
and at times in the last three months i
was like how am i ever going to get back
to work right i'm not sleeping there's
so much going on and even though there's
still so much going on things are more
manageable and at this time during the
day it's actually i mean we've always
said this that like this is the ideal
schedule for working moms working mom
because we get to be in the studio for
like a few hours and then really work
from home the rest of the day yeah so
i'm really excited about i'm excited to
be back and just start to
you know get back to normal as a mom
new normal the new normal and i'm i'm
really here for it and also like i had
the most productive weekend like i don't
think anyone's ever accomplished more in
a weekend than i did best feeling
because not only did i parent raise a
child raise a child that's huge two
bryce as well don't forget bryce oh
don't forget price we have our new
studio accoutrements thank you to the
wonderful toasters who i believed were
named molly and shannon or i'm just
getting confused with molly shannon um
for giving us these lifelike pillows of
bruno and theo honestly when we walk
into the studio it's very jarring
they're extremely lifelike they're
extremely lifelike even when they're not
here they're with us
i miss price so much she's been extra
special extra good so not only did i do
that i am cleaning out my whole life i
rearranged my kitchen like everything
makes more sense bags and bags of
garbage like just getting rid of stuff i
did my closets yesterday i went to gavin
de gras on sunday night at city winery
it was chef's kiss an intimate evening
with gavin
and it was really ideal it really was a
well-rounded weekend for me and i know
we're going to talk about your weekend
because it was probably a little more
exciting just a little but before we do
that to officially
commence
the maternity leave i think we need to
say a few things oh wow first is you
know
thank you so much for still being here
you were doing patreon you know
podcasting two weeks after you gave
birth like really as we said setting an
unrealistic expectation for women and we
love that we really do i'd also like to
give thanks to everyone who showed up
guest hosting with me like everyone was
really gracious with their time
and
i was just you know very grateful for
everyone especially ben and taylor
strecker who i relied on a lot heavily
um and you know in the coming weeks ben
has become such a star here like if
there ever was a day where like you
needed to like mom emergency like just
know ben can't wait to get back like he
gets so much positive
reinforcement and i feel like we found a
good balance of like not bickering and
like getting you know
negative feedback from people so really
major thanks to everyone who showed up
[ __ ] out gave us their time their energy
shannon i made so many new friends you
made so many new friends this was really
so great for you i know so like i was
really happy if you're having a baby and
stuff but like for me um you know me and
paige tax me and shannon text like it
was really good sophia me and sophia
like really exciting for my personal
life i love that and for me it was great
because i got to watch all these
episodes like as a lay person as a lay
person i love being a lay person that's
your like new favorite thing to say i
know and it's like what did i say before
for the word regular person with
probably no particular
player matter i think you probably said
regular person okay well i'm a lay
person and i loved being a toaster these
last few months and you know i it was
really great but i am like
overcome with joy to have you back
obviously because there's literally
nothing better than a jackson claw
extravaganza
two it's just like very um it's much
more work when it's not yet it's double
the work it's double the work it's the
picking stories it's keeping the
conversation going it's finding times
for the ads helping that person like
promote whatever they came on here to
promote like really
funny juggling a million things yeah and
so i am overcome with excitement that
it's over but i did have a great time
yeah that's all that's exactly what you
could hope for all good things all good
things
so oh by the way i saw you at the gavin
duggar concert i'm not gonna lie i watch
margo's stories and then i tap through
yours because you guys literally posted
the exact same well do you see what i
said we literally were filming at the
exact same time so it looked gorgeous
and you know what i feel like the
perfect place for you to bounce back
into
socialization is obviously at a concert
but a concert where you can like sit and
eat and drink like how nice i never
thought about like what a great venue
city winery is for a concert no it was
really nice and so gavin has a new album
coming out he has three songs that he's
released so far but the evening was
really him playing the whole album for
us explaining the songs the
album is really like a love letter to
his parents which i knew from his social
media but he was like explaining every
single song and there's one song called
like freedom which is all about his
dad's life and like you literally know
his life story from the song and it's
really like he has these thoughts he
writes them down and he sings them like
they're it's not about like the be even
though i like the b he is definitely
like the songwriter of a generation he's
so [ __ ] good and talented every time
he's in new york like where the gavin
girlies let me go and see him
he's one of my favorite artists so it
was perfect to go see him after two
plus years of not being at a concert
last concert i went to a celine dion in
march 2020 right and
you're right it was the perfect middle
ground except like he was playing some
bops and i wanted to like i wanted to
get up and dance because like once i get
you know a song in my heart like
i can't be stopped no of course but it's
a perfect transition for you from like
never leaving your house for two years
right it was a really nice night out and
i'm so happy for you it was wonderful
yeah i was happy for me as well and you
got merch i know well i used to we used
to go to so many concerts before coped
which i love like concerts are
probably my peak serotonin
and i used to like to get one piece of
merch from every concert so i could like
remember that i even went and saw sam
totally totally you know
and then i was like well i have to get a
t-shirt for gavin one because i hate
what i'm wearing
and two because i need to remember like
that i came here and have the memory
i'll see it in my pajama drawer and be
like oh good times yeah so normalize
like getting merch at concerts no i
literally show up to concerts in a shirt
that i can throw away just so i can buy
a t-shirt and then like that's what i
wear it's like so much pressure taken
off you don't have to figure out an
outfit for a concert because you just
wear the merch yeah i forgot about that
that i used to do that too and then i
showed up and dana had already bought
her merch and changed into it and i was
like style icon alert literally i got
the same shirt and we were twinning and
i literally had i was just wearing a
t-shirt under my cool jacket and it was
so small and horrific i didn't want to
take my jacket off it was
so many problems for herself and gavin
was supported and what was it like going
to a gavin de gara concert and that was
a girly who was followed on instagram by
gavin degraw so it was like really
interesting because i didn't want to tag
him in all my stories but i also like
wanted him to know that that i was
supporting that i'm there and like i'm a
big fan not too big and we had a great
time and you did amazing and here's what
you did on stage did he respond to you
no i tagged him in one story so that
like he knew that i was there
and he didn't respond can you see any
post i don't know i didn't even look i
don't know i guess i could look now yeah
he's the type of um artist who like
doesn't do his social media because it's
like
very like he's like you're telling me i
have to make a reals now right right
he's too busy focusing on the art on the
art you're right yeah okay let's see if
he ever saw and do you know what
prompted him yeah he saw it oh
he left you on red
that's okay that's okay he's busy you
know no it's it's totally fine it's fine
it's totally i wouldn't have even known
if you didn't make me change i'm so
sorry i thought for sure he didn't see
it like who wouldn't respond to you
you're so charismatic and beautiful well
he also saw it yesterday my stories
might have expired so he's like what did
this [ __ ] tag me in oh well then that's
the worst yes not to make the situation
like worse but then it's like he didn't
even know you supported you're just like
a fan now you know you say mentioned my
story like
yeah okay you're making it work sorry no
it's totally fine it's totally fun
i was there for the love of the music
the fact that he follows me is like just
a bonus you were there for the love of
the music yeah genuinely like the music
was so good i'm so happy for you if you
have a chance to see gavin in your city
take yourself out for a night on the
town if you ask me
how i'm doing i would say i'm doing just
fine he really is like
a bang machine
machine and if anybody from team gavin
is watching there were two songs i
really would have loved to hear if you
could just for the next time
finest hour
and i have you to thank okay just you
never know i mean kylie jenner does
watch his podcast so phillip phillips
like
if it got to philip it could get to
gavin that's the thing we really have to
be careful what we say like in the last
couple months the show has just like
blown up to every important person on
the planet and we really just have to
watch our mind our p's and q's because
we have to stop talking about people
because they always hear it but
the point of the show is talking about
people i don't know what to do and what
if i like have a really hot take that
needs to be said but like i know somehow
it's going to get to that person what do
you do do you neutralize the tape jackie
that's literally what we were talking
about before the show started like we
have the hottest take on something going
on right now no but we will have a hot
tape it's not a hot take so obviously we
can't even talk about it you know yeah
it's so tough being like so popular and
famous
but we do our best you know sometimes it
depends on the take but like even i
would say it to their face so i will say
it on the show yeah no and you are the
queen of hot takes so queen
um i have a few things to tell you oh
first is that so i had like the busiest
weekend on thursday i was in austin for
a meet and greet for spritz at specs it
was fabulous dogs came babies came it
was just everything were you kissing
babies i was kissing babies this one
child was just like not into me at all
were you much green i was butchering her
and the dad was like give her back and i
was like nah oh now you know what it's
like to have claudia as your aunt but um
do people actually have you kiss their
babies no and i'm like can i hold and
they're like are you kidding of course
i'm like really and i just like play
with them until they start crying how
old would you say these babies are the
one i think her name was like evie like
evelyn or something they weren't
allowing her eating a cute name and she
was so cute she was at like a great age
too where like she was like you know
dexterous but she couldn't tell me no
you know could she walk
i don't know she was being carried but
she looked like big enough like maybe
she could take a few steps you know but
she couldn't run away from her she
couldn't run away um and she was so cute
and like i try not to like you know
obviously kiss him on the cheek but like
i'm just like the type of person when i
see baby like i am gonna kiss it and i
just think it's inappropriate especially
like in a pandemic so i don't kiss
people's babies when they bring them to
the mean greets but just know like it's
all i want to do like i can't see a
baby's big delicious cheek without
wanting to just munch on it is that
crazy i don't think that's that crazy
and like
you have you could ask permission but i
think some people would let you give
their baby a kiss on the cheek it just
feels wrong and especially when the dad
is around and the dad doesn't understand
like obviously the power of the toast
he's just there to like support his wife
i think he would be like why is this
strange why is
why is this random woman in the liquor
store like licking my child's cheek yeah
but okay don't lick keep your tongue to
yourself but like if i met kylie like i
would let her kiss harry on the cheek
obviously but that's that's
you assuming like i'm kylie which is so
nice but i'm not i think you are thank
you um so on thursday i was in austin
and then friday i flew to live so i had
my friend's birthday party um this
weekend which is what i went for but the
night before the birthday party i went
to dinner at craig's you know celeb hot
spot and i have the most interesting
factoid about craig's ready sure do you
know what they were playing the whole
night
you're never going to guess gavin degraw
little mix
i was like
i have to remember this interesting
factoid it was so crazy i'm like take me
to craig's i sit down marry me at craig
i sit down you know what they're playing
take a sip of my secret potion i'ma make
you fall in love and the playlist was
just like so little mix after that it
was little mixed radio on spotify i was
really surprised because you know it's
like very high brow i would like to
expect that from craig and it made me
see craig and his business in a whole
new light no wonder why it's so popular
and everybody's clamoring to get in 100
percent bury me at craig's oh my gosh
i've actually been to craig's even
though there's so many like cool fancy
restaurants i've never been to because
i'm like a big loser but i have been to
craig's and
it's delicious
it is it's really delicious yeah it's
like one of those hot spots where the
food is actually like better than like
the hive yeah yeah like people are
actually going for the food and like
that's what made it cool it's extremely
delicious so i had a great weekend
nothing crazy just you know hobnobbing
with celebs la i went to nobu malibu um
just being in malibu it was like really
so beautiful you know when i go to i i
like going to l.a is fun but like i'm
even more like cemented in my beliefs
like i could never live there i was just
about to ask you obviously like we're
never moving twilight it's too far it's
too like different from you know being
new york people but like when i go to
l.a i'm like
this is paradise oh no when i go to l.a
i'm like this is not real i could never
live here i'm always like i would love
to live here but in malibu i was like oh
my god imagine i mean you need like 25
million dollars to like have a nice
beachside
shack literally 15 million dollars um
malibu is so beautiful and special i
could really like see and it's so laid
back and like more real like you know
more real yeah like it's more
i don't know like
i don't know what i'm looking for it's
like more down to earth because it's
with nature and the elements yeah it's
like an hour outside of like beverly
hills el um like west hollywood proper
yeah no like when we're in la
west hollywood-ish i'm not like i'm i'm
clamoring to live here no no no no but
like when you get out to the burbs yeah
and then you're eight and there's like
just so much sunlight and
obviously the weather
i obviously would never move there but
i'm like
this is must be nice oh and i'm sorry
the most important part about my trip on
saturday i went to lunch at the beverly
hills hotel with brian oh yeah and a few
friends
and me and brian are talking
and you know whenever i'm out to like
any sort of meal in l.a like i'm not
even looking at the person i'm with i'm
always looking around like looking for a
celebrity and at the beverly hills hotel
like it's celeb hot spot cause you can't
take pictures no paparazzi is allowed
there and this group walks in and they
like stop because there was a dress code
and one of the guys is wearing like a
tank top and they were like we need to
get you a jacket sir so like their party
was like stalled right behind our table
and i'm like
oh my god
it's rupaul
and like of all the people i could have
run into especially sitting there with
brian like to have run into rupaul
was
so special and it's like the only person
me and brian could equally like die over
you know and it was so he he see i
didn't want to bother him he seemed so
nice he was rolling with his crew it was
drag con in la this week which is like
this huge drag convention they have in
la new york so that's obviously why he
was like out and about it was so
shocking to be in his presence he's so
tall
he's so like dapper well dressed it was
it was honestly probably the craziest
most um
impacted i've really ever felt by a
celebrity like his presence is so big
and you didn't even say hi to him no i
mean they have like a policy at the
beverly hills hotel like
[ __ ] off you know so it wasn't going to
like but it's like no approach policy
it's an approach policy i would be lying
if i said i didn't like sneak a couple
pictures of him he didn't see but i just
like wanted them for myself you know
yeah to remember it was so crazy like
forget he's also just like the type of
celebrity who's so famous so rich and
not he's not like social he doesn't go
out you know on the town paparazzi with
miley cyrus you know like yeah he
doesn't really leave his house so it was
just it was crazy i'm really happy for
you when you sent the picture we were
all just like shook and like what a
better like to be with brian and see him
you love to see it i also saw tyga i saw
that kid from shameless the little one
um but rue was like really the
major moment and when you were out in
l.a do you just like get this feeling
that you're about to be discovered
yeah and also the whole time i was so
upset i kept trying to find for my
instagram stories we run l.a
and it's like not a real song no it's
not it's a
uh
conflagration what's the word of like
two things
a blend a blend but there's always this
word that i'm like reaching for yeah no
it's one of those words we learned not
combination conjugation no it's like
conflation conflation
wow i totally conflation over inflation
okay it's it's like a remix
yes it's a what was i even saying oh
yeah we run it's a it's a
conflation
of the song from shaw's we run light and
kris jenner's original song i love my
friends okay but no by the way i'm sorry
the theme song for shaw's of sunset is
we run l.a yeah but never we love la no
but i was trying to find we run l.a like
the shadows of sunset theme song i
googled it i found the name and it's
like not on spotify it's like a fake
song
so i couldn't get it for my instagram
stories and everything i posted i wanted
to do we run lay and then for my i did
like a photo dump at the end of the
weekend and i wanted to do we run but i
thought people would think i was
actually writing like i run la and like
that was like too embarrassing that
would be really embarrassing but if you
put music notes on both sides they might
get it we run l.a
so it's a really nice weekend i'm so
happy to be back like in the town of
real people my friends my family i'm
just
it was enough you know yeah every cub
every like three days in l.a is enough
for me i've never been i've
we've done like pretty long stretches in
l.a and i've never been like i have to
get out of this town oh i have i just
love that town that's so weird it's so
weird because i like hate
i wonder how i would feel about new york
if i didn't live here despised and i
came i think i would hate it more than i
do now yeah of course because if you
were visiting here that would mean that
your family doesn't live here and really
the only reason you like you can stay in
new york is because all of your friends
family college high school everyone
lives here you don't think i would look
around like
no
bright-eyed bushy-tailed y
see
that was good thank you
two bucks
three bags
one me
okay that was okay by the way in the
newest episode of kardashians
did you die from the fact that khloe
kardashian references annie just as much
as you do she's a uh hannigan stan she's
a hannigan stan she's an annie girly
yeah i'm sure true watch danny live oh
yeah i guess that's why
and maybe it was in the fall was before
annie live had aired but maybe chloe was
keeping up with the casting
announcements like we were right who's
true was really invested when chloe was
like we got annie i was like excuse me
the [ __ ] did you say that's like the
most random niche reference that you
like hung on to from annie live we got
annie talk to my husband that was his
thing oh right zach did that yeah so for
her to have like latched on to that too
it's like we are so maybe she watches a
toast
duh
we got annie yeah except when she was
saying it was october before whatever
sorry sorry
we have a lot of kardashians today but
it's like real [ __ ] so um you know
duh yeah sorry should we just seven then
let's save it and we have a lot to we
actually have so many stories like so
many things didn't even make the cut
you'd love to see it you do it finally
so here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
honey thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes
is a thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best
ones it finds to your cart imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites when you check out
the honey button drops down and all you
have to do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that site and if
it finds a working coupon you'll watch
your price drop so it's really so
premium it's free to download when you
use our link and it literally saves you
money i've used it for years on makeup
food electronics clothing literally
everything they have so many partner
websites
um and they'll even offer cash back at
thousands of stores so it's like earning
cash just for shopping i have a new
computer and i've been doing so much
online shopping and yesterday i was like
where has honey been oh my god you
didn't go to
and literally i was like join honey.com
it's seared into my mind and then i
checked out on all my carts and the
little honey icon was turned orange and
popping up and it saved me so much money
i also got a new computer and the first
thing i did i was like join honey.com
toast i made a big mistake huge if you
don't already have honey you are
straight up missing out and by getting
it you're doing yourself a solid and
you're supporting our podcast so we'd
never recommend something we don't use
and we are honey girlies through and
through and you can get honey for free
at joinhoney.com toast that's
joinhoney.com
toast
it's free to download it saves you money
like i really don't feel like i should
have to explain this to you no any
further like no the brand speaks for
itself it's giving canva pro it's giving
him a pro and today's episode is also
brought to you by best fiends once you
download best fiends the best game that
you can play anywhere even without an
internet connection
which is great when you're stuck without
wi-fi you will just be having the time
of your life you can collect tons of
fiends that get powered up as you play
more levels every win brings new
challenges so there's thousands of
puzzles to play they have new in-game
events that are added all the time so
with thousands of levels there's always
more to play go ahead and let enough is
never enough be your mantra so if you
travel a lot or you're sometimes like on
trains where you don't have wi-fi you
know like how unbelievably boring it can
be but best fiends is here for you
because it is a super fun game with tons
of different levels that lets you play
without wi-fi connection so that means
planes trains automobiles whenever um
you can be constantly entertained
stimulated by best fiends and it's just
so much fun
download best fiends for free from the
app store or google play plus you can
earn even more with five dollars worth
of in-game rewards when you reach level
five so that's friends without the r
best fiends why be content with having
enough when you can have more best
fiends always satisfies satisfies your
needs for more they have more puzzles
you can have more me time and more fun
check it out it's a great game and also
the fact that you can play with that
wi-fi is just like a premium experience
because like all games should be that
way and none of them are
yeah best fiends available for download
for free from the app store or google
play you're my best fiend you're my
husband
okay our first story big news kim
kardashian covers the sports illustrated
swimsuit edition and pens an emotional
letter to her younger self
kim just checked off another career
milestone with her sexy debut cover for
sports illustrated swimsuit and she's
clearly feeling good in her skins she is
wearing skim's swims the mogul and
reality star who has perfected the art
of the bikini selfie for her
millions of instagram followers was
photographed by greg swalls in the
souls
okay
i'm sure it's
a l s-w-a-l-e s falls swallows look it's
walls bro
swolls looking swoles in the dominican
republic for her s hi swimsuit moment
posing fresh face in a nude skins bikini
and matching sheer gloves yes gloves
with a bikini okay so kim is one of
four's s-i swim cover girlies mae musk
is another one mae musk is another one
sierra and uh uni you me new we're the
four so i have a lot of thoughts on this
my first is that like love seeing kim
getting recognition
you know how i feel
but something that was really liked
about si swim was like they were
constantly introducing us to like new
curvy queens so i'd never heard of kate
upton hannah jeter like there were
always people on the cover like the girl
who i hadn't like never heard of and
then i became huge fans of and like kim
is like such an obvious choice and i
love kim and she should have definitely
been on it but like i don't know i kind
of missed the days where it wasn't like
so celeb focused like sierra even you
know what i mean yes very interesting my
take is i miss the days of just one
cover a grade it's not a special edition
so yeah and it's like also everybody's
like focusing on the kimchi like if i'm
one of the other girl he's like if i'm
may i'm i'm a little peeved i'm just not
even that like i just think that for the
consumers it's just like instead of
there being like the one to watch it's
like the four and they all just get a
little less shine i completely agree it
used to be like if you were chosen as
the one like your career was never the
same yeah like yeah you were made and
now they started doing like multiple it
was three and now it's four that's a lot
i think it's like yes i agree it's like
not as special to have been chosen and
like i kind of like that like they
really spent they had all these swim
searches from like across the nation and
they found like random girls who were
beautiful and unique looking
who never would have been discovered
otherwise i don't know i just feel like
it's just different and i i love si swim
i think like they're an amazing company
they did everything victoria's secret
could never do like and i really said
and they've been doing it since before
it was cool coolest thing so i so
support them like a hundred percent
these are just like my thoughts and i
love kim don't get me wrong it's just
like so obvious can i just like i love
you know how i love it okay of course
and i don't have to say it and i love as
i swim and just for some reason like i
didn't give me the reaction that like
you would expect from me and you want to
know why
this photo shoot like
beautiful
just looked like all of kim's instagrams
you know what i mean i felt like
s i swim like their covers are so
sickening and like you see they travel
like 45 hours like the most random
[ __ ] beach on the planet wake up at
the crack of dawn and this just looked
like you know kim has photo shoots all
the time and she's always going on
vacation and she takes sick photos for
her instagram and this just looks like
the same caliber as honestly some of her
instagram photo shoots that's such a
good point
yeah i was just like a little and this
is so crazy of us to say i know but like
i was kind of like
yeah
and then i was also thinking like on the
one hand
this is like a big to be on the cover of
s i swim is like one of those 10 pokemon
in a career but on the other hand like
kim is
beyonce beyond and it makes sense
because every single swimsuit she's
wearing is skim swim so it's like really
a promotional thing and i'm sure when
she was launching swim she was like okay
what's a campaign that we can do like
what's the most iconic swim moment yes i
swim of course so it really is like a
very happy marriage very good synergy
here but it's also just like giving
ad yeah and nothing like revolutionary
you know i just missed the days where
like i would discover like new models
who i thought were so sickening from s i
swim like yeah remember in chrissy tegan
nina ogdahl and i forget the other
girl's name we're all on the cover and
like the little tissues were hanging out
like there were just so many iconic
moments i mean kate upton and her you
know amazing body hannah jeter like her
whole like remember it was like her
vagina's out like kate up and was on the
cover and then she was on the cover
again and then they did three covers all
different kate upton like that was
interesting now it's like okay next year
there'll be five people because it's
giving like participation award like we
can't we can't choose a winner you're
all winners jackie that that that that
that's it like it's giving participation
award and i have to be honest like if
they just had one cover and it was me
musk like that would be a statement yeah
or by the way i'm so sorry i don't know
this other girl's name what is her name
you mean she's sickening looking and it
should have been like that's the type of
situation where if it was just her i'd
be like oh my god i don't know this girl
i know her now let me follow her on
instagram love her like yeah but she
just kind of got shafted yeah yeah cause
it's all about kim and like you had to
know when there was like kim and three
others like we're only talking about kim
so i'm just like i don't know and by the
way i follow mj day on instagram and
like she
posts amazing content of all the
different girls and like if it was any
one of these like new unknown girls just
by themselves like that
that's like a historic moment like how
we now look back on kate upton and it's
just like i don't know like
i was underwhelmed yeah me too
considering like i'm the target audience
for this right and i was overwhelmed
overwhelmed for sure which is shocking
but like i just i was thinking like why
is this not like
everything yeah but you know what it's
always fun to get like new kim content
yes yes and as i swim is always exciting
so make sure to pick up a copy yes and
they're always supporting the toes so we
love them we love are you ready for our
next story a little more kardashian news
because it's like big news courtney and
travis are officially married she
confirmed the marriage and shared
intimate wedding pics captioned till
death do us part they took some black
and white photos outside the courthouse
in a low rider convertible that with a
sign that said just married like very
classic
very gorgeous very stunning she's very
gorgeous to me and there's a lot of
confusion here because they're like is
this the official wedding blah blah blah
mj was there and travis's father randy
barker and they appear to be the only
witnesses who were at the loki's
ceremony so what i believe is happening
is they are getting married this weekend
in italy
i don't i haven't heard that it's this
weekend but oh that's what i heard oh
okay and it would make sense to do it
like you do it if you get the license
you have 60 days but right yeah and i
don't think mj will be traveling for
that so like she gets to be at this
wedding and then they get to take their
license to get married overseas no it's
like super special and i liked that but
like i don't know why today's like i'm
kind of being like a kardashian hater
but like between the vegas wedding and
then this and then we have another one
this weekend it's like enough ready that
is true i'm sorry like and when i got
the people notification i was like cool
like i just everything these days just
makes me go cool no i think i'm becoming
i think it's just been like a lot with
the card and don't get me wrong like i
don't want this to get back to kylie you
know but like i will stand till the day
i die but the last couple weeks it's
been a lot like with the new show and
then kim and pete like it's just been a
lot travis and and it's hard to muster
up the same enthusiasm for every single
thing milestone every single sister all
of the time so like and i do like love
courtney and travis and i have a lot of
thoughts actually about scott did you
watch his most recent episode um
it's definitely like a weird dynamic and
i was actually thinking before bed last
night i wanted to mention this on the
show that conversation with um kendall
and scott at the end was so asinine like
kendall was fully gaslighting scott she
was like
saying she didn't have a birthday party
and then she was like well why why why
would i put courtney in a bad position
it's like well didn't you just say you
weren't having a birthday party yeah she
was just like not be she was not giving
what she thought she was giving and she
was like scott literally re-watch the
tapes like we're on record like no you
actually if you rewatch your tapes you
would look incredibly silly because
that's not what you said you know what's
so funny it's like she's the biggest
supermodel in the world like there's no
one cooler no one more like beautiful
stunning and smart and like when it
comes to her family like she's just the
kid's sister it's true and it's like you
know how like margot gets like
exasperated in like an argument like
that it's like and she had to like storm
up and walk away like that's just
kendall that's so true but that's why we
love the kardashians like because at the
end of the day they're like just sisters
yeah yeah um and did you see like the
internet being lit ablaze by the fact
that kendall does not know how to cut a
cucumber of course and you know what
like it was warranted because i watch
that scene like she's like she's gonna
cut her wrist off no first of all
between her arms being crossed over and
then when she gets to the regular spot
her finger is so close to the front of
the cucumber and she's almost gonna chop
off her fingernail i'm like damn that's
you know
they have been famous since she's so
young they've been famous for most of
her adult life where like courtney kim
and chloe got to be like 21 before they
got really famous so i think older
kendall has had like a chef literally
since she was like 10. yeah so the fact
that she doesn't know how to cut a
cucumber like is actually not talking no
not shocking but then like don't be
so proud like no and then when chris is
like calling chef to cut off her let
jeff do it let chef do it like because
she i think she probably wanted to look
like no i make my own snacks yeah
because she really is like that one of
all the girls the one who's like i'm not
like other celebrities like i'm real i'm
a nerd i love to paint she's like that
her vibe is always very much giving like
i'm a regular girl when i think out of
all them she's probably the least
regular no and it's like just seeing
that scene like actually exposed her
more than if she just lets chef make her
a snack let chef cut it up even though i
was really interested to see what she
eats because she's like so perfect
looking yeah we love a balanced queen
pretzels cucumbers and hummus that's a
good snack that is a good snack um
so i just thought that episode was
interesting but back to courtney and
travis i'm like and i really i believe
in their love i think they're great for
each other but i'm like getting i'm i've
become like a little
what's the word fatigued fatigued but
also is it desensitized and like
overexposed yeah it's just like it's a
lot of the same story multiple times and
yeah i
i'm not so into like the scott
travis courtney like dynamic especially
because at least for me like it feels
like courtney and scott like are
strangers they don't know each other
they haven't been in love in such a long
time that there's no way that it still
hurts yeah you know so it's like why and
scott is really like the family brother
at this point why can't the brother come
around like what are the thoughts on
them inviting scott places i think scott
should be invited everywhere because
he's just like the brother at this point
like there's no risk for like travis
that courtney's gonna fall back in love
with scott i don't think she's been in
love with him since she was 21 like yeah
so she wasn't even in love with him like
for the last five years of their
relationship yeah and then also it's
been five years since that yeah i don't
think she even looks at him like that
she's so in love with travis like scott
does not pose any sort of threat like
he's so enmeshed in the family and as he
said like
he lost both of his parents at the same
time and the kardashians came in to be
there for his to be his family like you
can't now take that away because like
courtney met someone else no i agree and
like i do think he was acting like a
little bit like a little insane at the
one-on-one lunch with chris but it's
like everyone is like lying to him and
like
talking about him behind his back and
like doing things where i think he would
actually just appreciate it more if
kendall was like i'm having a birthday
party i'm not inviting you just because
like i feel like it'll be weird but to
find out like on instagram from your own
family like that's probably what hurts
the most and i don't think the way he is
responding to it is like 100 right like
he was a little mean to chris at that
lunch when it's like chris is the queen
like have some respect yeah um but i
understand the frustration i do but i
also understand but see like who is it
coming from so kendall was like i don't
want courtney to be uncomfortable did
courtney ask
kendall not to invite like is courtney
asking her mom and her sisters not to
invite scott to certain things or are
they making that decision on their own i
don't know
because it kind of feels like they're
all protecting courtney and like it was
courtney's request yeah but it's like
unless there's stuff we didn't see it's
not like they broke up and they've been
like hooking up can't quit each other
they're
it's a very like neutral
well i don't know like at the end of the
e-show
he was like working towards getting back
like she was like there's a list of
things you need to do for me and if you
do them i will entertain can't even
imagine them kissing no it's like now
they i'm sorry like chloe and scott are
end game like i know that's nice
it's like
they are end game it's like what he
loves about courtney
is chloe like they're family so they're
really similar they they have some sort
of chemistry i know it's crazy and it's
like biblical and they could i don't
think they could ever have kids together
because that would make it weird but
i'm telling you like there is something
there the kids would be
not half siblings they would be like
three quarter siblings it's not a thing
and also i guess the big bombshell from
this week's episode that everyone like
wanted us to talk about was the fact
that chloe admitted that her interest in
like are back together but like
i don't care that's the petition we need
a new um button instead of a gavel like
fatigued like when i just can't talk
about something anymore yeah and i'm
there with courtney and travis i'm there
with like
i'm there with a lot of kardashian
related stuff and that is not um
a reflection of how i feel about them
it's just like it's been a lot these
last couple weeks because of the new
show and like they've just been in the
press a lot no and like so much of what
i like there's so much from the show
that like is giving me life and it's
just not like the
the overall narratives it's like chris's
house chris is china this is chris's
room of china i never really knew like
what my dream aesthetic was like a lot
of girls romanticized like you know
capri as their like you know
coastal grandmother like everyone has
like an aesthetic that and i didn't know
what mine was i've been aesthetic-less
until last week like my aesthetic is
whatever chris jenner's house is like
elegance opulence dripping in diamonds
like kind of old antique looking
furniture but like making it rich yeah
like
yeah like couches with like bed skirts
ew i would literally never buy that in
my entire [ __ ] life but i was like
chris i was like that is the most
gorgeous couch i've ever seen my only
thing about the new house is like we've
seen some aerial photos of the lots
because they're next to each other and
like i'm someone who's i'm interested in
the land and the views and the bucolic
nature and i need to see her backyard
because based on like the aerial drone
footage that we've seen like they it
looks kind of like there's not a lot of
land you know who has the best backyard
courtney yes yeah she literally like
backs onto a cliff so there's like
mountains galore kim's house is very
kind of enclosed which i guess is like a
safety thing um it's very enclosed it's
like a hidden garden which is a vibe but
i love courtney's backyard no i don't
know how she's ever gonna move
especially like the house that they
looked at how do you go from that
backyard to no to that backyard and by
the way they both have mega i was
watching a tick tock someone did like
aerial footage google earth from
travis's house to courtney's house they
literally lived seven blocks away from
each other not seven blocks seven houses
away from each other they're both so big
just move into one
do they have enough bedrooms for all
those kids though well travis's kids are
like older
so i don't think the oldest one lives at
home landon alabama's like 18 she
probably will be moving out soon like
would it kill rain and penelope to share
a room like my god
is that like so crazy like everyone does
it share [ __ ] room get a bunk bed
you'll have fun you will have fun i'm
sorry sharing your room as a kid is like
literally the best what [ __ ]
four-year-old wants to be by themselves
like
yeah no i totally agree or rain and
mason can share a room yeah like we
shared with you rooms mixed gender no no
no sorry i forgot you know who was who
but like no mixed gender no i don't
think so but
like
sharing a room as a child is literally
the best [ __ ] in the world yeah and it
teaches you how to share like i think
just like having your own room is very
akin to like only child syndrome yeah
you know it's in the same vein vein and
normally sharing rooms especially for
celebrity children yeah no like they
don't just make houses with unlimited
rooms and they're already like so
privileged like you actually are doing
them a favor by sticking them in the
same small room with a bunk bed like you
just learned so much about life you get
so close with your siblings like i
wouldn't i shared a room with margo most
of my life actually all of my life and i
[ __ ] want to trade it for the world
even though at the time i was like
michelle and leon rowe no it was the
best yeah the best good times good times
are you ready for our next story i don't
know if margot would say the same oh we
got to get margo on here
was here twice last week like just
giving us everything it was so generous
of her like to share her time with us we
know how busy she is and you know what
it wouldn't have been
friends and family months without her
she needed to come on and let everyone
know like how she feels about her sister
100.
are you ready for our next story
speaking of people who are no longer
sharing rooms i'm sorry i'm not there
yet is it the next story that's brought
you by way yes and one of these people
which is the bad margaret uses to pack
her things and run away from us and also
in this next story someone needs to put
their [ __ ] in the way luggage okay and
get out these days travel looks
different but no matter where you go
away offers a range of suitcases and
other travel products made of different
materials like polycarbonate aluminum
durable nylon and they offer it in a
variety of colors and sizes so whatever
you need to bring with you away has
luggage that will help you make your
next trip more seamless i don't know
like what people use if they're not
using away my away suitcase is my best
friend i actually have two now because i
can't get enough and ben is always using
it just everything about it is perfect i
have the carry-on size but i also have
the big checked luggage i don't check
bags that much but when i do i use the
big away but the little travel carry-on
is like the best bag on the planet it
has the laundry bag it has the thing for
your undies in the middle we're always
saying like where do you put your dirty
undies when you are on a trip uh a way
has that taken care of for you yeah i
don't know if that's the official
purpose i don't know if it is how we're
all using it but it's ventilated it has
holes it should be the separate from
like your other tings
yeah all of the way suitcases are built
to last with durable exteriors that can
withstand even the roughest of baggage
handlers every suitcase comes with an
interior organization system so i guess
that's what it's called jackie the
interior organization system that
includes a built-in compression pad
for your dirty idea for your dirty ideas
it helps you pack more and they also
have a hidden and removable laundry bag
that separates your dirty clothes there
it is they have four 360-degree spinner
wheels guarantees a smooth roll even the
most hectic of airports and train
stations they also have a tsa approved
combination lock that keeps all your
belongings safe their newest line of
soft side suitcases are made with a
durable water resistant nylon exterior
that is made to last a lifetime they're
expected to expand
1.75 inches so you have the flexibility
to pack even more into your trip there's
a 100 day trial on everything that away
makes so you take the product down the
road love it live with it travel with it
for 100 days and if you decide that it's
not for you you can return any
non-personalized item for a full refund
during that period no ifs ands or bucks
away offers free shipping and returns on
any order within the contingency u.s
europe canada and australia so start
your 100 day trial and shop the entire
away lineup of travel essentials
including their best-selling suitcases
at
awaytravel.comtoast that's
awaytravel.com
toast great okay real houses in miami
stars lisa and lenny hawks are getting
divorced
um
i'm trying to process it last week we
spoke about how there was like the blow
up at the club when i hosted with margo
she had no idea what you're talking
about but i had to say it because what
was the story i didn't hear so
there was they were saying that uh lisa
was at a club and lenny showed up with
his new girlfriend and there was like
words and it was like got crazy and then
everyone denied that that had happened
but it's like then where did this story
come from anyways now lenny confirmed to
page six that he and lisa are going
their separate ways after 12 years of
marriage he said lisa and i are getting
divorced a few weeks ago i denied this
because i'm trying my best to protect my
family during this process this is a
very difficult time and i would ask for
some privacy so that we can best take
care of our children who mean the world
to us lenny also confirmed that he is
dating austrian model katharina mizepa
but claimed none of this happened until
after the decision was made to get
divorced yeah i saw like a weird
paparazzi video of them like standing
outside prime 112 just like hugging
kissing and like looking into the camera
it was so weird oh that's weird writing
you sent it to me i figured you saw it
because you were literally lenny and
lisa's like number one fan i have a
google search yeah he has yet to file
for divorce from lisa but told page six
that they've contemplated divorce for
the last several years he said i tried
my best to avoid it for the sake of our
children who we love deeply we have been
living separate for months and made the
decision to divorce last month it was
after the decision was made that i
started seeing katharina it this is
something that lisa was well aware of
before it happened our issues have
nothing to do with filming the show
yeah sure no actually i believe that
because they've only been back on tv for
a year and when they came back they were
so toxic yeah but it's like it's weird
because when they filmed the last
installment of miami afterwards they got
separated and that's when emotional
affair now they're filming this again
and they're getting divorced and like
maybe sometimes putting a spotlight on
shows things that were previously unseen
literally and mentally
um
or it's a coincidence yeah like for me i
still like when i think of lenny and
lisa and like why i ship them like i
think back to like literally 10 years
ago what we saw and they're so different
now they're so toxic both of them like
the way that like
lenny speaks to lisa is like not okay
the way that lisa like
the way that lisa just
like dismisses lenny like they're really
not good for each other like they're
extremely toxic and so while i'm sad
like i actually do think it's the right
decision
what the [ __ ] there's something crazy
going on in this building oh there's
people there uh can you stop we're in
the middle of something
can you imagine we're in the middle of
lenny and lisa yeah no it's like they
don't even care no they don't care it's
like they don't even care that lenny and
lisa are getting divorced it's
disgusting
what is that noise sorry guys
it's like too big to ignore no i don't
know it's a little scary i know i know i
thought it was like you know like a bad
sound at first
oh my god
no something's it sounds like they're
taking it sounds like someone's like
getting robbed
at this point you must be able to hear
it
yeah of course of course
yeah we're almost done
yeah that's not acceptable
what'd they say
what happened
they're doing construction
it's like no one respects the show it's
disgraceful it's disgraceful don't they
know that philip phillips watched joey
don't phillip phillip watch and do they
know that lee said lenny are getting
divorced like nobody [ __ ] cares
nobody [ __ ] cares oh my god um
well so like you are the resident stan
like what is your take away from this
okay i feel sad obviously and i ship
very hard but i do sometimes feel like
when people go on tv and they show us
like the bad side of their relationship
i actually sometimes feel like it's a
healthy sign i agree and so where is
that line of like okay we're you're not
you know pretending everything's perfect
versus like oh you showed us you were
toxic this whole time and you know like
there is there's like adrienne and paul
massif who were so [ __ ] toxic and
some people were like every couple
banters but then like literally five
days later they're gonna know but it's
like okay it's like you and ben like how
you bicker on the show and like i think
it's a sign of a healthy relationship
that you can show like that not
everything is like i agree so fine and
dandy and like this is how we talk to
each other sometimes but then there is a
line where it's like oh no like these
two people are unhappy and we've been
watching it this whole time the line is
paul and adrian i think that's literally
the perfect everyone used to comment on
how much they bickered on beverly hills
but then it wasn't even bigger it was
like literal hatred for one another yeah
but i felt like lisa and lenny's
dynamic
not this season
i guess because they kept talking about
the emotional affair
yeah without that but like i just keep
thinking about like the dinner that they
went to with like his parents for
example like i thought that they were
being like a cute funny happy miserable
no
that was like a little that was in my
opinion that one crossed the line like
the like the dinner interesting talk
about your in-laws like that like
on tv why i thought she was saying these
things
lisa yeah what'd she say i don't know i
just remember her like saying kind of
like negative things about lenny's mom
oh i don't i don't recall that that's
how i remember it but like regardless
this is like not surprising but it is
sad it's yeah it's sad and
i'm
looking forward i don't i'm team lisa
and i think the reason i like lisa and
lenny so much is because i like lisa so
much yes and so i just like hope that
she it seems like even though she knows
about all of this like he's moved on
she's the one who keeps denying and
saying like his behavior is
inappropriate so i think she's kind of
slow to come to like she's less okay
with it yeah do you think that they
signed a prenup did she mention that
this season
uh
i don't know because he's a lot of money
yeah
i don't know i don't think it's ever
been mentioned well you know what lisa
was like really giving absolutely
nothing on this recent season of real
housewives of miami and this divorce did
just buy her another season so for that
she should be grateful
well no i think she would have been on
any because like she gets along with
everyone like she's one of those people
that it's like oh half the cast isn't
talking like lisa throw a party she
won't last forever though if the
franchise that goes on forever like i
don't think she if she keeps keep kept
giving the same energy she gave last
year i don't think she could
go further than like two or three more
seasons she was so
boring yeah talking about like her
nannies and her manicures like come on
yeah well now she has more to talk about
but i also think like her and lars have
like a really nice friendship and now
they're both single yeah that's true
no so i do think this has breathed new
life into her
time on the show did you watch the
premiere of beverly hills yeah of course
we haven't spoken about it we'll do a tv
recap okay okay yeah we'll do tv recap
are you ready for our next story sure
because even though we haven't been
covering the ins and outs of this trial
amber heard blames johnny depp's dog for
the infamous bed poop incident because
like it was years ago when we first
found out that in you know the back and
forth between amber and johnny there was
a story
that uh unfurled that she took a dump on
his bed you know in a fit of rage and
now as most people do she is saying that
that is not her she denied under oath
that she was the one who left feces in
the pirates of the caribbean actor's bed
in 2016. instead amber blamed the act on
depp's dog boo
he said boo had eaten johnny's weed when
she was a puppy and had bowel control
issues for her entire life um
that's like really concerning amongst
some other issues
amber said we regularly regularly had to
take her to the vet to try to figure out
what was wrong with this dog i've never
met a dog that was quite like this she
testified that boo liked to burrow in
the bed and would sleep with the couple
she also said that they had to leave her
in the bed so she wouldn't be encouraged
to go to the bathroom which would happen
almost immediately when she put her down
on the floor and sometimes it happened
in bed too
i don't know there's like a difference
in human feces and dog feces when it
comes to girth length cause kind of dog
was boo right unless you was a [ __ ]
rottweiler yeah i don't think
boo you could confuse it with human
feces but that's just my opinion as a
feces expert i agree but like maybe a
big lab makes a big [ __ ] so here's the
thing
i'm having a hard time believing
okay
let me see how big is it i just googled
boo dog breed hoping that like you know
but when he wrote johnny depp okay
because like there's a little banter i
just got it's a yorkie
it's a yorkie i'm okay that what that's
like a three pound dog right lit smaller
than oh for reference
this man's poop could not be confused
for human pube no no human pup
could not you see him this is to scale
this is the size of bryce
yorkie i would say
this big yeah half of bryce yeah there's
no way that dog's [ __ ] could even come
close to being confused for a human [ __ ]
not at all case closed so what i found
to be most interesting i i get served so
much johnny and amber content on tick
tock and i definitely think the content
i get served is like skewed negatively
towards amber but one of the most
interesting videos i've seen in the last
couple days because the trial was on
break for like a week and now they're
back and it's the cross-examination of
amber heard and so you know she has said
that you know she got seven million
dollars in settlement when she divorced
johnny and she wanted none of it she
said that she donated
it all to the aclu and the children's
hospital of los angeles so when she was
being cross-examined johnny's lawyer
who's like a [ __ ] fireball she was
like
can you is that true that you donated
and she was like yeah i pledged that and
the woman's like no no did you donate it
and she's like yeah i pledged it and the
woman's like you're not listening i'm
asking there's a difference between
donating and pledging and so it like
turns out that she like made this whole
statement she was giving the seven
million dollars to these organizations
she pledged it but never paid it
which is so shady so shady
wow so again so so much of the content
i'm getting is like anti-amber um
and amber heard follows 55 people on
instagram and i am one of them and it's
so
unique to me
and
i don't understand why he's crazy he's
like up until this point we really
haven't spoken about the trial just
because there's so much and there's so
much history no and i mentioned one
thing i think when taylor's tracker was
on and i got a message from someone
being like literally you hate women you
don't support the me too movement like
[ __ ] off [ __ ] up i haven't even taken a
hard stance i'm just like
reacting to what i'm seeing right and
like and a lot of people believe johnny
and they can still support the me too
and a lot of people and men can be
abused and a lot of people believed
amber like before all of this happened
and now are seeing things and like it's
their opinions are changing so i was
like i'm not [ __ ] talking about the
stupid-ass trial anymore cause like
literally being accused of not
supporting the metoo movement goodbye
insane so what i was just gonna say is
we haven't really been talking about it
for various reasons mostly just being
there too much to it to unpack and we're
not like the legal minds to do so and
let the the courts decide and that's
what's happening right now right and
we'll share once that's been decided um
so maybe like amber has been tuning in
every day because it's like oh this
place is this show is like an escape she
follows you on instagram
and she was like
this is the only thing i can watch
that's not talking about it oh my god i
have to see if she still follows me
honestly but you know because it's like
you haven't really said anything i guess
you said it was taylor's trucker but
like maybe up until this point she was
like girl with my job has my back
okay she does still follow me
maybe she's listening right now with
phillip phillips
and making a duty
i mean i've like messaged with her
that's so crazy i don't even remember
doing that
but not since 2019. she called me babe
and she said i looked cute oh my god
team member
[Laughter]
um
so yeah i just like don't it's there's
so much information about this right i
mean i think the most interesting thing
that's come out of it i think one of the
biggest headlines is like amber you know
milani cosmetics which is the drugstore
um
makeup brand which is fabulous by the
way um amber like submitted into
evidence this color correcting palette
that she used over the years while she
was you know in an abusive relationship
with johnny depp and i think she said
the abuse started in like 2015 or
something and the milani cosmetics
posted on their tic toc like the palette
that she's holding up wasn't released
till 2017 like it didn't even exist so
her like she was like this is my my
bruise kit she like that's what i used
to call it saying like for years she
used it when milani cosmetics fully came
out and said like
we didn't even make this product until
2017. wow did then johnny's
team like submit that i don't know
that's a good question
wow johnny's legal team like is not
[ __ ] around and amber's legal team is
like
but again okay i'm only getting targeted
with content that's like so pro johnny
because there is a movement of women who
literally stand outside the courthouse
like die for johnny love him so much so
i think i'm on that side of tick tock so
it's possible that there's like other
videos i just want to be like totally
honest right and also like you send me
videos because i like you were sending
me what you were seeing and it's like
these things spliced together with like
literal like circus music behind it to
show like this is clown so what it's
making it seem like it's like amber's
attorneys like cannot find their find
their ass from their elbow and johnny's
are like killer like you know robert
shapiro like yeah the best so again i
think i'm on like a really specific side
of tick-tock and that might be shaping
how i see the trial but again like
where i think i've landed is that like
this was an incredibly mutually abusive
relationship and there's there's video
recordings that are being played in the
trial of like amber admitting to
physically abusing johnny right so i
think that like they're both they were
in like an extremely toxic relationship
where they were both being abused and i
think that's like
i think the fairest way to kind of sum
it up yeah but again we were none of us
will really ever know no but also feel
free to send claudia like amber team
amber tic-tac-toe like maybe if you saw
it in that light i'd love to balance out
the algorithm like i'm really but i
i i just think like there isn't team
amber content that's what i think okay i
don't know i really don't know that's
why but i support the metoo movement i
just want to say and also men can be
abused so yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
give us a song it's the final story
[Music]
to
[Applause]
[Laughter]
good one
thanks
fifth and final story little tmi megan
fox tells her stylist that she cut a
hole in her blue jumpsuit to have sex
with machine gun kelly remember what we
were saying about like overexposed i'm
i'm there with these two also right so
megan fox posted a carousel of a
sickening outfit that she wore this
weekend and she included in the carousel
screenshot of a text to her stylist
style me maeve she said was this blue
outfit expensive because we just cut a
hole in the crotch so we could have sex
i just you know what it's giving it's
giving like juniors who lost their
virginity and being like sex
you know like thinking it's like cool to
have sex and like bragging about it like
yeah
because it's like okay it's one thing to
cut a hole in the crotch to have sex
it's another thing to like say that to
your stylist and it's another thing to
post it yourself
letting everyone know that like you had
sex in your jumpsuit yeah no it's just
like i don't care and like we get it you
guys are like really into each other
like [ __ ] off yeah i like i'm really
like so spent with these two drinking of
the blood like it's a they're they're
travis and courtney on crack yeah and i
think they're they're i think travis and
courtney get so much press
naturally and i think like
megan and
mgk like manufacture a lot of the crap
that comes out about them i think some
of it because i think like they were
just this couple where separately they
were stars but not in the press every
single day like together they just like
multiplied their and it's been so good
for both of their careers right and so i
think a lot of it like people are
genuinely interested in them and like
they are getting they are engaged and
they and you know a lot of it is very
natural but sometimes it's like we need
to share a text like this to shake
things up yeah but also they were in the
news a lot um also we need to talk about
the bbmas we need to talk about cardio
television oh yes we do and
kylie was there kylie was there was
travis
stormy looked so amazing stormy was best
dressed stormy looks so amazing um
i guess this is just like the day where
i'm being critical of the kardashians um
like travis just like coming back into
the world without even acknowledging
like what the [ __ ] happened at
astroworld is so bizarre to me it's so
bizarre the way they cut it out of the
show because you know chris's birthday
yes but
it is an ongoing legal thing and also
like and i think when it even happened
everyone was like blaming the
kardashians and like he is a very
separate man with a his separate teams
like chris has nothing to do with astro
world honestly so it's like really not
even necessary that they sully the show
with talking about it i agree especially
since it is a huge legal matter so why
but kendall was there right and these
scenes of kendall in miami getting iv
drips with haley
is a very confusing part of the timeline
because they were in houston so people
are saying that like
that was just filmed at a different time
and like they're
making it seem like she was in miami do
they think we're that stupid right so i
don't know what the real thing is but
like
okay so my problem really isn't with the
kardashians because i don't believe in
blaming the kardashians for literally
everything in the world and this was
like a travis thing but the way travis
is like now re-entering i know he had
his first public performance he's now at
the bbmas like the way he's re-entering
society like is leaving a bad taste in
my mouth yeah like no acknowledgement
and i know he's probably extremely
limited in what he can do because
you know making donations or
making a statement like legally he can
be admitting fault and like he i i get
it but it's just weird to me but don't
you also think it's weird on behalf of
the bbmas like to have him to have him
and have him perform yeah um because
weren't they the ones who banned morgan
wallen right right and then morgan
william performed this year right but he
was banned from the awards from uh
showing up from winning like he didn't
win anything right and he's and he like
said something really really bad but
travis like
people died like it's worse right right
yeah yeah right
so like no it's just weird to me like
the way this travis thing is like
they're just totally ignoring it i guess
it's like a unique pr method but like
it's just it's giving like insincerity
and it's really making me feel weird
it's making me feel weird and then just
like seeing him and and kylie and stormy
walk the carpet it's like i love kylie
and stormy but it's like what like it's
weird yeah
so but that wasn't even kylie's standing
by her man she's standing by her man
he's saying that up down left right and
center right
but that wasn't even the biggest thing
from the bbmas the biggest thing from
the bbmas is literally cara delevingne
being a [ __ ] menace bothering the
[ __ ] out of everyone especially meghan
the stallion megan stalin posted a
picture cropped out cara delevingne from
the middle she was being so annoying all
these videos of her on the red carpet um
bothering megan like touching her dress
and like hiding behind the step and
repeat and then like getting on the
floor taking pictures of doji cat like
go away no
so extra doing the most i think when she
first started doing megan's dressing
like megan was into it but then did you
see the video i think it was not skinny
but off that that posted it to her story
it was like a video of doja cat in her
chair talking to megan and cara and she
said oh carrie i love you and then she
said i love you guys together
do people think they're a couple
no i don't think so because also it's
like why would they be seated next to
each other
it's just coincidence that the person
that cara was obsessed with on the red
carpet she also gets to sit next to
inside maybe she needs someone to move
so she could sit next to megan and
stallion i don't think that they're a
couple
i think that like selena gomez and
cartelaine could be a couple they're
like always together recently oh really
i meant i wanted to watch her episode of
snl i watched a monologue it was okay
what'd she say anything literally
nothing um but the after party was
apparently like wild went to 6am post
malone was there television that's what
i think of of the after parties not like
what kim's post right you know
cocktail hour yeah it was drinks with
the co-workers so um
i don't know what card levine was doing
there and i don't think that she's
dating me no making this italian has a
boyfriend sorry party okay or until
recently she did
and
megan looked so [ __ ] annoyed by cara
like i was living for megan's reactions
but like what was she doing there
i don't know she was also acting like a
little um like
wild at the met gala yeah and also at um
that party that uh
that you were at oh my god yeah she was
like on stage with the mayor and she's
like
she was just being like a little wild
like she's kind of nuts kind of yeah so
i don't know what's going on with her
but like i'm i just i'm curious if she
woke up like with a pit with anxiety
because like
the content was everywhere she probably
wrote into unburdening yourselves and
was upset to see we took the day off she
was like checking claudia i went to an
event this weekend and then acted a fool
i just became so obsessed with this one
girl that she really did like
she's just been a little weird lately
when you put it that way we have all
been there
right but and by the way i do believe
cara delevingne is like a party girl but
this is compounded because every public
event we've seen her at recently it's
bizarre and it's like the behavior is
getting more and more strange with
literally no explanation yeah yeah and i
do believe she like likes to have a good
time i think she's like a party girl
through she's literally like a social
light you know she goes out
so but also it's worth noting like we
she's been a celebrity for like 10 years
now we've seen her at so many events so
many red carpets and like that's not
what she was doing no something's
changed yeah there's something going on
with cara
but um there's something about cara i
don't care enough to dive into it let's
dive into the real housewives of beverly
hills tv recap which is brought to you
by manscaped attention everyone are you
ready to be blown away men and women
alike asked for it and they have
listened our friends at manscaped just
relaunched the ultra smooth package it's
back your new favorite tool and
complimented the lawnmower 4.0 to get
that smooth shave finish you're looking
for this special grunt shaving kit is
here to help you buff shavings yeah you
heard that right it's here to help you
buff protect and shave your most
sensitive areas it's time to crop that
bush of yours and get right to the roots
with a discount just for mint from
manscaped get 20 off plus free shipping
at manscaped.com with the code toast not
only has manscaped brought you the
electric chamber that you and your men
both love to use but they're now
bringing back your favorite razor so you
can be set and trimmed front to back
this is a durable yet sensitive razor
that's perfect for him and her the crop
shaver is not your average razor it's
smaller thicker with a micro comb bar
that allows for the best possible shave
from any angle and the crop exfoliator
and crop gel are both vegan cruelty free
and sulfate free so you know the goods
down there are in good hands without
compromise it's time to get up close and
personal with the best tools for the job
the ultra smooth package from manscaped
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code toast at manscaped.com that's 20
off plus free shipping with
codetoast.manscape.com
get smooth with the relaunched ultra
smooth package from your friends at
manscaped perfect gift for the man in
your life and it's also something like
you can use which is so nice ben has it
i got it for him a while ago and it's
really everything of the sort it's
always a great gift father's day is
coming up get the grindshaver um real
housewives of beverly hills premiere was
good but like a little boring obviously
we had to boring yeah like
yeah i thought it was boring
that's crazy because anthony onwards
what happens live said last week when he
was teasing it like probably the best
premiere ever oh i totally disagree i
think the best premiere ever of the real
housewives was the season where russell
armstrong passed away and like in the
beginning they had to be like
i mean in my opinion yeah yeah so um i
don't know like i thought the footage
from the robbery was so crazy so crazy
but i don't know like
i don't want to be mean but like a lot
of like a lot of it was like kind of
cringy
what do you mean i don't know like when
pk got there and then like
he was hugging mauricio and then like
derek went in and like kissed mauricio's
back like i don't know it's just like
weird
oh okay i missed that i don't know it
really like rattled me yes the whole
situation and like seeing the footage
that they had and like even seeing
duriet the next day and what's so crazy
is that her kids don't know thank god
thank god but it also means that she
can't process and grieve in her own
house i know so i know people were like
it's weird i don't think it was weird i
don't think it was weird either like she
needs to be able to break down she
cannot do that at home like it's such a
blessing that they don't know mommy's
going out for the night like that's not
so weird yeah and i'm sure like in those
apps in those days in the aftermath and
even now like she has insane security
like she's never been more secure sutton
was being really weird deranged and like
it makes me think because that's not a
normal reaction and sudden is like she's
quirky but she's not
insane and that was and she's feeling
reaction pathetic she's not
heartless it made it seem like she
didn't believe dorit or something or
maybe that she like didn't
i don't know how you could hear like
your friend got robbed in the middle of
the game at one point and with your kids
and not be like oh that's a really
[ __ ] big deal like i've been putting
out fires let's drop everything it was
so weird to me and i want to hear her
explanation
and i don't know when she's going to be
on watch happens live next but it was so
[ __ ] weird yeah and it was like
and i feel like beverly hills is at a
weird place right now because like the
group is is divided in a lot of ways and
like i'm it's erica
and lisa which for me is just like the l
like i used to be obsessed and like
they're just not it anymore um and it's
them versus like
sutton garcelle and crystal
and then like dorit and kyle are like
somewhere in the middle yeah and i think
this season they'll take sides yeah and
i do think they'll take lisa and and
eric aside just because lisa erica kyle
duriet and teddy mellencamp are like
this best friend crew yeah um which
makes it and that's what garcia was
saying last season that's why it's like
not even fun to be with this group
because like there's a core group and if
you're not a part of it you're like an
outsider yeah you're like left out and
you're supposed to like not talk about
the fact that like you're not included
close with everyone but you feel on the
outside right yeah so um aside from like
the read stuff there wasn't a lot of
drama outside but there is like this
great divide in the group and i think
it's like from last season and it's much
more obvious now because
garcelle sutton and crystal have kind of
like
unionized in a sense like they're
they're like an official crew now yeah
and they spent the off season like
getting closer and it's nice yeah and
it's just so funny because we said this
about sutton and crystal when they first
like
butted heads early in last season and
it's just like sutton butts heads with
everyone she meets because she gives us
these like ins weird bad vibes but it's
like not even worth your time to like go
after her like have beef with her
because
she's harmless
and it's just so funny how now like
crystal can see that they have so much
in common uh and it's like we all tried
to tell you literally yeah
but you know what's interesting is kathy
hilton because she wasn't in the episode
she's not in the episode but she is
close with like uh with crystal
yeah and this season like we see that
her and kyle like
get into it yeah but and lisa rinna
seems to be in the middle
kathy
um is like the
up until re up until this point i think
she has been like the most well
respected kind of matriarch of the group
nobody [ __ ] with kathy but i do believe
there's an incident this season in um on
the aspen trip where like kathy gets in
trouble for doing saying something
really bad oh
i knew that there's beef like something
happens in aspen yeah but i don't think
it has to do with kyle like from what i
heard and this is totally unverified i
hate to even say but like i think i read
it on reddit it's like kathy
calls
sutton's like friend or assistant like a
slur
again totally unverified like i hate to
even put that out there but that is like
what the beverly hills fans are saying
okay but then there also
is
an issue between kyle and kathy where
lisa is like somehow in the middle of it
where it's like lisa get out like this
is a family matter yeah so like like we
got we got really nothing um
concrete like with the drama in this
episode because we were all obviously
focused on to read and i think to read
is extremely strong and it literally
sounded like so scary but we didn't like
move forward in like the storyline yet
in the drama and like the plot yes yeah
okay agreed so um also i watched summer
house last night reading in part two
second and final part which always just
like leaves you wanting a little more
which i enjoyed um the reunion in
general was just i guess because it was
a good season like there's just not that
much and like there clearly something
went down in winter house because it is
ice cold in there divided and there's so
much that they're clearly not saying but
the
tension between paige and lindsey
there's
nothing that we've seen it's so weird
nothing that we've seen has been able to
explain that yeah and i don't even think
and then no one even said like you'll
see on winter house because i'm sure
that's like an annoying thing to and
it's not even like andy asked like what
happened between you two that we
obviously did not see but
uh something
and it must be like really weird to have
filmed an entire show and then have to
film the reunion for this old show
just all very strange yeah it was a good
reunion but for me like i am on team
paige and sierra and like everyone was
again so i'm like even the guys like
carl being such a loser in my opinion so
like
and like luke coming after paige it was
like tough to watch as someone who like
i really am team paige yeah i all season
have been team paige and sierra but i do
think in the reunion
um they didn't do themselves any favors
and that if you were a lindsay and
danielle
like team member you wouldn't you felt
vindicated because
they did seem to come out on top but i
also just felt like paige and sierra
might have been limited in what they
could say based on like other things
that had happened like they weren't as
forth like sometimes at a reunion like
you make amends you know everything even
though we get into the trenches we come
out and it's like we're good but there
was none of that because it seems like
there's something else going on yeah
um i guess we'll have to wait and see
with uh winter house yeah and speaking
of we're having a really kind of
exclusive
interview coming up yeah we're about to
record we're about to record with austin
he has he messaged me and said i have a
lot to say i feel like my name has been
besmirched and i would like to speak my
truth and i said of course you are
always welcome we love to let people
speak their truths here so he'll be
joining us literally in 20 minutes to um
speak his truth and the podcast will be
out tomorrow the podcast will be out
tomorrow but we're doing something
different if you're watching us a video
right now the austin episode will be up
as a video once it's recorded yeah in
like two hours because he wants to clear
his name and we are open to hearing yeah
and he was a big topic of conversation
at three union last night so we're going
to get some summer house answers from
him as well so thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning toast the
monday morning show where we deliver the
fast factorization each and every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and where podcasts can be found
so it's spotify i can stitch your public
radio everybody walks all the places
swivels and podcasts finance more until
supervisor our viewer beautiful stunning
and smart we are we'll see you tomorrow
for hump day goodbye goodbye
you